[Música]
pues yo nací en polonia en los años 70
durante un periodo de comunista que fue
muy difícil para la gente de mi país
no había trabajo o si había no había
dinero si había dinero no había comida
no había ropa
y luego de recurrir a un mundo de
conocer a los demás fue un sueño de
muchos pero la realidad de muy muy pocos
y aún la gente se iba los que podían
salían desde el país para no volver me
graban
[Música]
y yo como hacía parte de una familia de
primero desplazados después refugiados y
después migrantes a mis 12 años acabé en
australia
y se me acabó el mundo
[Música]
me encontré en un país extraño donde
todo todo era diferente la comida las
costumbres la gente donde no tenía a mi
familia excepto excepto a mis padres no
tenía amigos y lo peor me quedé sin
palabras y los que me conocen saben que
para mí eso es muy difícil porque a mí
me gusta platicar
pues qué pasó
eso me provoca una determinación
increíble a aprender una nueva manera de
ser de vivir de hablar de comer y además
me provocó las ganas de hacerlo una y
otra vez una y otra vez
y así después de australia acabe en
suiza en italia en francia aprendí
idiomas por gusto y por necesidad y
acabé haciendo un trabajo internacional
sobre todo como investigadora social
entonces van a namibia tailandia pase un
rato en haití cortando telas después del
orégano en 2010 para hacer viviendas
para la gente que se quedó sin ellas
[Música]
bueno y qué pasó
con todas esas ganas de aprender yo un
día me di cuenta que yo estaba muy bien
en las situaciones
donde tenía que seguir aprendiendo
y un día acabe o me pare en un país que
se llama birmania y que está en el
sudeste asiático
es un país de 50 millones de personas un
país budista donde todavía hay guerras
civiles que propagan estragos en la
población donde el banco mundial dice
que 25% de las personas viven con menos
de dos dólares al día
un país de contrastes extremos donde la
riqueza cultural es increíble y la
pobreza material es extrema donde la
gente sonríe cuando está infeliz e
incómoda y donde el afecto no se muestra
en público
[Música]
y qué pasó en ese país me enfrenté a una
situación que yo desconocía totalmente
por primera vez en mi vida yo vi el
trabajo infantil
y por primera vez desde que tenía dos
años me quedé sin palabras
qué es el trabajo infantil
por primero
[Música]
es una falta de derechos humanos
fundamentales que experimentan los niños
es un trabajo que provoca daños físicos
y psicológicos y que entorpece los
futuros de los niños y sus familias y
como hay un vínculo entre la pobreza de
los hogares y el trabajo infantil este
tipo de trabajo genera más pobreza y más
pobreza y más pobreza
para darnos para darnos una idea del
problema en birmania cuando hicieron una
encuesta en 2015 se dieron cuenta que
más de un millón de niños birmanos entre
5 y 17 años están en una situación de
trabajo infantil lo que quiere decir que
casi 10% de todos los niños de ese país
trabaja
muchos de ellos siguieron a sus padres
que atravesaron el país en búsqueda de
su trabajo muchos de ellos migraron a
través del país por su propia decisión o
fueron mandados por sus padres a
trabajar en fábricas restaurantes casas
en las ciudades y en las fincas en las
zonas rurales
pues me puse a investigar esa cosa me
puso a trabajar a trabajar con los
investigados y hermanos y tuve la
oportunidad de pasar mucho rato con las
familias de esos niños y con los niños
mismos y descubrí una cosa
[Música]
y lo que sentían ellos no era tan
diferente de lo que sentimos todos
cuando estamos en situaciones de
dificultad yo escuchaba sobre sus sueños
sus penas sus desafíos
sus esperanzas y sobre todo las de las
madres y lo difícil de mi trabajo es
siempre he sido lo el hecho que yo pues
acababa la investigación que me llevaba
a unas conclusiones y yo da
recomendaciones a los demás
trabajaba con organismos que desarrollan
políticas e intervenciones para prevenir
y eliminar este tipo de trabajo pero yo
cuando estaba con esas familias y esos
niños para mí que me preguntaban cómo me
puede ayudar
hacía lo que podía daba clases de inglés
después de sus horas de trabajo
a veces sacaba a los niños de su uso de
su trabajo y intentaba de ayudar a sus
padres para quienes prendieron sus
estudios hasta que a unos niños de unas
niñas de servicio doméstico que en
birmania es muy duro
pero bueno cosas pequeñas
yo había aprendido mucho de las familias
y sobre todo de las madres de sus niños
y una de las cosas principales para mí
fue que las madres son las que en
mayoría toman decisiones al respecto de
sus hijos y son las madres que se tienen
las más responsables por el futuro de
sus hijos y cuando no lo pueden asegurar
eso provoca una ansiedad un miedo una
desesperación
[Música]
sentimientos que creo que las madres y
hermanas ticas australianas y polacas
sienten igualmente de esto estoy segura
pues qué pasó
pues yo había emprendido todo eso pero
no creo que lo entendía muy bien hasta
el día que yo me volví mamá
y entonces si me di cuenta de los ya y
ahora necesito ayuda por favor
[Música]
y me puse a pensar en cómo eso se podría
lograr porque yo sueño con un mundo
donde todas las mamás puedan asegurar el
futuro de sus hijos
y las políticas que tenemos y las
recomendaciones que yo hacía pues
faltaba un poco de empatía y bueno eran
a largo plazo innecesarios por supuesto
pero no adaptadas a la inmediatez de la
demanda
pues mi sueño es de crear un fondo
solitario entre las mujeres de todo el
mundo para las que tienen más pueden
ayudar a las que tienen menos para que
nos podemos acompañar entre nosotras
guiarnos apoyar económicamente en los
momentos claves y asegurar que todas
podemos acudir a las oportunidades
económicas que muchas veces nos faltan a
causa de falta de competencias
conocimiento
y comprensión
[Música]
una especie de plataforma solidaria
basado en un concepto
de cadena de favor
[Música]
yo creo que juntando nuestros esfuerzos
de los más pequeños a los más grandes y
teniendo en cuenta que los derechos de
la mujer van de mano con los derechos de
los niños y que los niños son el futuro
podemos lograr un desarrollo sostenible
y de quitarle
que se está buscando en todo el mundo
espero mucho que os juntáis este sueño
pura vida